actually I don't totally mind being
Lebanese it has a certain cachet and
none of the connotations of being
Palestine
though I am dragged there a few more
times against my will I do start to love
Lebanon again family vacations become
fun my cousins turn back into brothers
and sisters new and improved versions of
the old restaurants and beach clubs
spring up like a lot of the other young
exiled Lebanese I find a home there I
return with frequency and as the country
continues to flourish I find myself
flourishing to take some years but I
begin to nourish myself not only on the
food with which my relative stuffed me
watermelon apricots rice chicken
vegetables homeless but on the love that
they give me and the opportunity to be
part of a culture that embraces me fully
I wish I could explain this how the
Middle East works I want to be able to
explain the culture and what is so
incredibly addictive and captivating
about it but I can't do this without
self-consciously feeling like an
Orientalist yeah okay well I'll try so
yes there is the muezzin the call to
prayer so amazing at Twilight and there
is the mysterious deeply spiritual feel
of the air and water it's like you're
constantly aware that all of the
valuable stuff happened here and there
are the smells and sounds and spices and
flavors and carpets and hookahs I
suppose if you're looking at it that way
but what really grabs you about this
very electric vibrant cut culture is
that anyone who is talking to you is
talking to you and looking at you and
thinking about you and trying to make
you another person feel good and
comfortable and full
and content the Arabic language is a
perfect example of how this works let's
say you order something in a restaurant
or you take a taxi or something else
that requires saying thank you to
someone okay well you don't you don't
say thank you you say god bless your
hands yes l'm a dick or or God give you
strength I was like a tiki lassi or
another equally lovely phrase I mean god
bless your hands think about that
wait before you do remember that you
would say that to anyone
Christian Muslim Jew Buddhist or atheist
it's an expression and while I'm here
let me just say that the word Allah in
Arabic means God it does not mean some
other special fundamentalist Muslim
daddy who hates infidels it is a word
whose denotation is the Supreme Being
okay so basically in the same way that
Spanish speaking people calling him vos
and the French called me yeah
Ola is just God sorry to get pedantic or
doubt your knowledge but I just had to
say that because you know in English we
say oh my god and God rest his soul and
all of the same stuff but somehow I feel
like we're taught here that if it is an
Arab saying it they are a fundamentalist
Muslim urging all believers to destroy
the infidels no not even close
oh and everyone calls you by a nickname
they just multiply the nicknames they're
often diminutive of your actual name
like Munna becomes moonmoon sama Sam
Soon Tala tell tune my name is La Ness
Julian Azul Dena's new gene Nonie or
BiPAP means oh my goodness the pet names
are so delightful
Habibi or its feminine habibti is the
most well known it means the one I love
but there is also
hi Yeti my life Ione my eyes Roy hey my
soul lb my heart
amaura like the moon I think that it's
it's kind of from the language and the
way that people use it that life becomes
this lovely thing you you share it with
other people you delight in their
delight you want to feed them love them
laugh with them make them feel good it's
nice also people just stop by to visit
you and it's not weird it's lovely and
on cellphones no one has voicemail if
you get a missed call you call the
person back it's like the whole idea is
to connect with other people not avoid
them it's delicious really it is and and
so I think from all of that comes this
need to to go out and touch and love and
dance and eat it's like you're on a
constant quest to meet everyone
the other thing about Arab culture and
well maybe I should say I don't know all
22 Arab countries well enough to make
such generalizations but anyway all of
that stuff that people love about Greece
or Italy you know the way that people
drive wherever they want whenever they
want whatever direction they want the
way that people get insanely angry at
you and then five seconds later they're
kissing you
all of those Mediterranean things
they're true of all of the Mediterranean
people's Mediterranean Arabs - I mean
we're not that different from the rest
of the world
Arabs that's all I'm trying to say